Hey guys, I brought you out to the mountains today. To show you a cool little camping hack
You can do with only three to four tent pegs. So if you're hiking backpacking or camping and forgot your stove
Here's a simple little hack that just might save the day now the idea here is really simple
We're just gonna push three to four tent pegs down into the ground
You can really go as deep as you want. You can see already a couple inches in it's really firm
Ihnihnihhjnbjo job u B bunih hnWe just need enough of a gap that we can build a small fire
Or put some hot coals in there to cook our meal
And I like the tent pegs facing inward here now the key really is to getting them all about the same height so in this
Case you can see it almost makes like a triangle shape and that's going to be just enough of a platform to put some kind
Of a cooking container on there, you could cook a can of beans, or you know a small meal
Just by building a small fire under here which we're gonna do right now
A lot of wrappers these days are made of aluminum foil
And you can use these to make a makeshift bowl for cooking in the wilderness as well
Here's how you do it start by laying out your aluminum. Foil the more layers you can get out of this the better
It's going to work, but essentially we want to just make some squares
And I'm going to use three layers of foil by folding it in on itself to make a nice aluminum
Square like this now if we flip it over with this side facing [down]
We can push our hand in and just very gently move the sides up around it to form a bowl shape
It's very important not to puncture the bottom while we're doing this but just like that
We end up with a pretty cool-looking little aluminum
Bowl
Now if you want you can use something like a tuna can or a cup as a mold to form your bowl a little bit
Better and when you pull that out, you've got a nice little cooking base. It should fit perfectly right on top
So just like that you got yourself a little Makeshift Bowl
And you can put soup water stew anything you want in there and light a fire and because it's made of aluminum
And it's three layers thick it should not burn through it shouldn't poke any holes
So let's put that to the test and see if you can boil an egg
So you can see we got our fire built in going the tent tapes are still in there?
But I'm letting them sit there for now because we've got a lot of heat those are going to burn down to coals and then
We just stoke the fire from underneath in the meantime
Let's fill up our little aluminum container with water and try using some of these farm-fresh eggs
And see if we can get them boiling these eggs are straight from my wife's chicken
And they're called easter layers because they lay a different color eggs, so it's kind of like an easter egg hunt every day
Just enough to cover the eggs is fine
Hopefully, we don't have any leaks in there, and we're going to find out here in just a second
So I just got the eggs off of the fire let them cool down a little bit
I got some river water here that I'm just going to drip over them to cool them down and a really cool thing about this
Guy is we boiled our water for probably a good [ten] to [fifteen] minutes
I'm really confident that we've got nice boiled eggs
And I don't expect you to have eggs with you when you're hiking or backpacking
But this is just to demonstrate that yes
It will boil water not a problem and look the water still holding up in there very well very cool hack guys
Let's crack these eggs open and see how they turned out
Beautiful. That looks amazing
Mmm. That's good. That's really good.  Now another cool trick
I learned is [that] if you don't have a spoon you can hack one like this. I have a 2-liter bottle
I'll show you how to make this in another video
So the really cool thing about having a little tent peg fire stove
Is that you can actually build the fire around it and it can be permanently set in place
And this way you can use things like cans of beans
Tuna cans you can boil water you can cook your food cook your stew
You can even use tinfoil if you have it to make a makeshift bowl and boil eggs
We've showed you how to do that, and it works really really well so all in all this is really cool
Hack to know if you're out hiking
Backpacking or camping and you don't have a stove and you need to boil water
We were able to boil our water long enough to boil my wife's eggs, and so now we're going to go enjoy
So there you have a guy it's a simple little stove that you can hack out of tent pegs in tinfoil
Thanks so much for joining me for this project video, and I'll be looking for you in the next video document